FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS WILL
COME TO ORDER. GOOD MORNING IN
RESPONSE TO THE CURVE IN
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCE
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW I
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE ONE
SEVEN FOUR SEVEN SEVEN ONE FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS O HOW
THE TELECONFERENCE A STONE
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE AND OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WHEN WE MOVED ABOUT COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. PRESSES
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE OUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL
BE ON MUTE IT AND YOU ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY. AND TO
AVOID. ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU. ANDWE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND TO CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS
AND- IN AS CLOSE OF THE SAME
MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY THERE
MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE. OF ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
NOW ON TO OUR COMMITTEE
BUSINESS WE HAVE FOUR BILLS ON
THE AGENDA TODAY. BEFORE WE
HEAR THE PRESENTATION ON THE
BILLS THAT THE STATUS QUORUM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
LET ALONE HERE LET ALONE HERE
OTOBO A SHOW ABOUT HERE
BRADFORD. THE EURO CAVIAR HERE
DAILY. DELHI HERE THERE ALSO
THE REST SO HERE WHAT'S SO. MAN
POURTANT TINO FORTINO HERE. THE
CONSULTANT NOTES A QUORUM HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED FOR FIRST ITEM
OF BUSINESS LET'S TAKE UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THERE ARE
THREE ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FILE ITEM. ONE EIGHTY
TWO EIGHTY THREE FILE ITEM TO
AB SIX SIX THREE AND FILE ITEM
THREE AB. FOUR THREE ZERO DO I
HAVE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. MOVED BY SENATOR
DRAWS OVER. CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
ADOPT THE CONSENT CALENDAR LOAN
HI MON HI PHOTO ABOVE A
SHOWBOAT HI BRADFORD. COPYRIGHT
COVER YO HI DALLY. DELHI HI
THERE ALSO TORONTO HI WHAT'S SO.
MAN FORTINO FOURTEEN L. I'D. WE
WILL PUT THE KIT WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HAS SIX OF US
AND WE WILL PUT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ON CALL. WE WILL BE.
WE WILL MOVE ON. TO HEAR FROM
AUTHOR OF AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BARRICADE HAND.
YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE
READY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. FIRST I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
EXTENSIVE WORK ON THIS ISSUE.
AND THEIR DEDICATION TO
STRENGTHENING PROTECTIONS FOR
VULNERABLE CONSUMERS ESPECIALLY
RIGHT NOW. I TAKE IT OFFERS
AMENDMENTS IN THIS COMMITTEE TO
STRENGTHEN THE GOALS OF THE
BELL. BY REQUIRING RESPONSE TO
CONSUMERS WITHIN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS OF RECORDING A COMPLAINT.
AND COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY THAT SERVICES MUST
TELL. CUSTOMERS WHAT
INFORMATION WILL BE NEEDED TO
RESOLVE THE ISSUE. WITH THAT
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT A B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY A BILL TO
PROVIDE NEEDED CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS FOR THE DIGITAL
AGE. THE PANDEMIC IS
ACCELERATED MANY TRENDS AND
REVEAL DEEPER GAPS IN OUR
SYSTEMS. THIS IS PARTICULARLY
TRUE. FOR ONLINE FINANCIAL
SERVICES. IF YOUR CASH FRANCE
SERVICE LIKE VAN PAY AND-
INCREASE IMPACT. WITH THE RISE
OF AD PAIN AND SO. WHEN HEAD
OVER A YEAR AGO. A LOT OF
FINANCIAL TRANSITION
TRANSACTIONS AND ONLINE AT THE
SAME TIME THE THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS LOST THEIR JOBS.
FOR EVERYTHING FROM SIDE
HUSTLES TO MUTUAL AID THESE
CASH TRANSFER SERVICES EXPLODED
IN POPULARITY FOR THE HARDEST
HIT THEY OFTEN BECAME A
SIGNIFICANT SOURCE OF INCOME.
AND A LIFELINE. THESE SERVICES
ARE A LIFELINE TO THOSE THAT
ARE INSECURE IN IN TREACHEROUS
SITUATIONS. THE APPS HOWEVER
ARE OFTEN FULL OF GLITCHES AND
SERIOUSLY VULNERABLE TO SCAMS.
WHEN PEOPLE ENCOUNTER PROBLEMS
ON SOME OF THE APPS ALTHOUGH I
WILL SAY NOT ALL THEY OFTEN
HAVE NOWHERE TO TURN AND CAN
FALL VICTIM TO ANOTHER SCAM
BECAUSE OF THEIR CONFUSION.
CURRENT REGULATIONS DO NOT
OFFER SUFFICIENT PROTECTION AND
ROLLABLE USERS ARE LEFT WITHOUT
RECOURSE. AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
SIMPLY REQUIRES CRASH TRANSFER
SERVICES TO LIST A CUSTOMER
PHONE NUMBER. FOR THEM TO GET
HELP PROMINENTLY ON THE
WEBSITES AND TO RESPOND TO
CUSTOMERS WITHIN A REASONABLE
TIME FRAME. I WANT TO KNOW THAT
I'M WORKING WITH THE INDUSTRY
TO FURTHER TAILOR THE LANGUAGE
TO BE CLEAR AND REASONABLE AND
TARGETED AT THE BAD ACTORS IN
THIS SPACE WHO ARE NOT
PROVIDING THESE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS. THIS BILL PROTECTS
THE MILLIONS OF CASH STRAPPED
FOR CUSTOMERS WHO RELY ON THESE
FUNDS MORE THAN EVER. IT GIVES
THEM ACCESS TO A LIFELINE
PROTECT THEIR FUNDS AND HOLD
COMPANIES ACCOUNTABLE. WITH ME
TODAY ARE SARAH ROBINSON
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC POLICY AT
THE NATIONAL CONSUMERS LEAGUE
AND CHUCK BELL PROGRAMS.
DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY AT
CONSUMER REPORTS. THANK YOU- WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND HAVE THE
SPONSORS WITNESSES- PRESENT. AS
A. WE WILL HAVE THEM PRESENT
CALIFORNICATION. A MODERATOR.
MODERATOR. MADAM CHAIR WE DO
HAVE A WITNESSES ON THE SPEAKER
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN LINES MUTED
ALL RIGHT SO WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND BEGIN WITH A TRUCK BELL.
GOOD MORNING THAT CHAIRWOMAN
WOUND AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CHUCK BELL
I'M PROGRAMS DIRECTOR FOR
CONSUMER REPORTS WE'RE A
NATIONAL NONPROFIT MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS SIDE BY
SIDE WITH CONSUMERS FOR A FAIR
AND TRANSPARENT MARKETPLACE.
THE POPULARITY OF CASH TRANSFER
APPS AND ONLINE SERVICES HAS
GROWN BY LEAPS AND BOUNDS WITH
MORE THAN NINETY MILLION ADULTS
IN THE UNITED STATES NOW USING
MOBILE PAYMENT APPS. IN OUR
pRESEARCH CONSUMER REPORTS HAS
FOUND THAT CONSUMERS DO
SOMETIMES HAVE SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEMS USING THESE SERVICES.
AND WHEN THEY DO THEY WANT TO
BE ABLE TO CONTACT THE COMPANY
DIRECTLY TO GET HELP QUICKLY.
YET THERE ARE FEW SERVICE
PROVIDERS MAKE TELEPHONE
CONTACT NUMBERS PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE LEAVING CONSUMERS
HIGHLY FRUSTRATED. A CRITICAL
POINT TO BEAR IN MIND IS THAT
BY NOT PROVIDING PHONE NUMBERS
MONEY SERVICE BUSINESSES ARE
LEAVING THE DOOR OPEN FOR
SCAMMERS TO POSE AS HELP LINES
FOR THE AFTER SERVICE. AND GAIN
ACCESS TO THE USER'S SENSITIVE
PERSONAL INFORMATION TO COMMIT
FRAUD. NEWS REPORTS BY YAHOO
FINANCE FOX BUSINESS AND-
DEPORT DETROIT FREE PRESS OF
REVEALED THIS PRACTICE IS
WIDESPREAD AND HIGHLY
CONCERNING. IN ADDITION TWITTER
AND REDDIT ARE FULL OF
COMPLAINTS FROM CONSUMERS WHO
ARE URGENTLY SEEKING HELP FROM
COMPANIES THAT THEY HAVE
ENTRUSTED THEIR MONEY TO. SOME
LIKE SIX OR ON TWITTER
EXPLAINING HE TRIED EMAILING A
MONEY TRANSFER APP COMPANY. AND
WAS NOT ABLE TO GET A RESPONSE
FOR TWO WEEKS AND IT WAS
DESPERATE AT THAT POINT TO FIND
A PHONE NUMBER FOR A CUSTOMER
SERVICE REPRESENTATIVE TO SPEAK
TO. SO AS MONEY TRANSFER APPS
BECOME MORE POPULAR AND
INCREASINGLY UBIQUITOUS
CONSUMERS ARE INCREASINGLY
RELIANT ON DIGITAL FINANCIAL
TOOLS TO MANAGE HOUSEHOLD
FUNDS. BUT THE LOSS OF FUNDS
COULD BE CATASTROPHIC TO
FAMILIES THAT ARE EXPERIENCING
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP. WHO ARE
RELIANT ON MONEY SERVICE
BUSINESSES SHOULD TO MOVE MONEY
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO SEARCH SO
HARD TO FIND HEALTH. PROVIDER
SHOULD BE REQUIRED TO DO MORE
TO PREVENT PEOPLE FROM FALLING
VICTIM TO SCAMMERS WHEN SEEKING
ASSISTANCE. SO FOR ALL THESE
REASONS AB THIRTEEN TWENTY IS
AN EXCELLENT FIRST STEP TOWARD
ENSURING THAT PROVIDERS LIVE UP
TO CONSUMER EXPECTATIONS TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE IN THE EVENT
THAT USERS ENCOUNTER
DIFFICULTIES. ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMERS THAT WE REPRESENT
CONSUMER REPORTS STRONGLY URGES
AND- I VOTE ON A. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY. THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE
SARAH ROBINSON. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE M
NAME IS ROBIN CALLING ON THE
PUBLIC POLICY MANAGER AT THE
NATIONAL CONSUMERS LEAGUE I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU AND PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IN COURT M. A. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY. FOUNDED IN
EIGHTEEN NINETY NINE AND THE
ELK NONPROFIT MISSION IS TO
ADVOCATE FOR SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC JUSTICE ON BEHALF OF
CONSUMERS AND WORKERS YEAH
ANYTHING ELSE WEBSITE AMAZON
.ORG WE COLLECT THOUSANDS OF
CONSUMER COMPLAINTS EIGHT A
LIFE THAT WE SHARE WITH OUR
NETWORK OF MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED BLOCK PARK PARTNERS. I
WOULD HAVE TOLD NINE ROUND .ORG
HAS RECEIVED ALMOST ONE
THOUSAND COMPLAINTS INVOLVING
MONEY TRANSFER SERVICE AND MY
CAT HAD BEEN MILD PAYPAL SOUTH
MEDIUM PRETTY TEN FEET IS
HUNDRED DOLLARS HOWEVER WE HAVE
ALL HEARD CONSUMERS YEAH FAR
MORE AND I'M TRYING CATER
ANYTHING HELLO AND WHY THEIR
ENTIRE LIFE HATING. ANYTHING
ELSE COMPLAIN DATA SIMILAR TO
WHAT ORGANIZATION HOWEVER AND
IT HAS YEAR AND A FINANCIAL
BUREAU DIRTY MORE THAN OUT
COMPLAIN ABOUT MONEY TRANSFERS.
CUSTOMER SERVICE THIRTY AT ST
LINE. OR IT'S NOT CLEARLY
AVAILABLE AT THAT TIME. THE
CAMERA HAD RUSHED INTO THE
BUILDING HOLE AND MONEY
TRANSFER SERVICES CUSTOMER
SUPPORT FRAMEWORK. YEAH AT
PUBLIC LIGHTING DAY CUSTOMERS
NUMBERS ON THIRTEEN JAN. MEDIA
EIGHTEEN THIRTEEN TWENTY OF
YOUR APARTMENTS AND MONEY
TRANSFER SERVICES MAINTAINING
CUSTOMER SUPPORT ONLINE AND
RESPOND IN A TIMELY MANNER TO
CONSUMER INJURY AND THE COMMON
SENSE CONSUMER PROTECTION
REGULATIONS THAT WILL HELP YOU
BEGIN TO FIGHT BACK AGAINST
FRAUD. WE APPLAUD AND FAMILY
MEMBERS OUR KING AND LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE AND WE ENCOURAGE
THE COMMITTEES MARKET. PLACE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NOW WE
WILL SEE IF HAVE ANY WITH IN
THE GALLERY SCENE NO WITNESSES
IN THE GALLERY ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB. THIRTEEN TWENTY SCENE NO
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPTLY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OF THE AB THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN TWENTY WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU DO WISH TO
COMMENT IN FAVOR AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE. ZERO PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO SIGNAL THAT YOU
WISH TO SPEAK. SURE THERE IS NO
ONE THAT HAS SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. R. EIGHT THANK
YOU MODERATOR. WE WILL NOW.
MOVE ON TO FOLLOW THE SAME
PRACTICE AND HEAR FROM
OPPOSITION WE DID NOT RECEIVE
ANY OPPOSITION TO A LETTERS TO
THIS BILL BUT WE DO UNDERSTAND
WE HAVE A LAST MINUTE.
OPPOSITION AND SO- WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND- TAKE THEM AND GIVE
THEM- A COUPLE. MINUTES
MODERATOR DO WE- I BELIEVE IT
AND I APOLOGIZE I DON'T KNOW
WHO EXACTLY IS VIA TESTIFYING.
AN OPPOSITION. ALRIGHT SO IT
SOUNDS LIKE THEY WILL BE ON THE
OPEN LINE THEY'RE NOT IN
OPPOSITION BUT THEY WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS SOME CONCERNS. DO WE
HAVE ANYONE ON THE LINE. THEY
HAVE NOT CALLED IN AS A WITNESS
THEY MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND I BELIEVE THAT
WE MAY HAVE THE SPEAKER JUST A
MOMENT. IF YOU SIGNAL THAT YOU
WISH TO SPEAK YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ARE JUST A
MONTH THIS ON BEHALF OF
ELECTRONIC TRANSACTIONS
ASSOCIATION. OUR ASSOCIATION
DOES NOT HAVE A FORMAL POSITION
AT THIS TIME BUT WE DO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS REGARDING
THE AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE
TO ABC THIRTEEN TWENTY. WE
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING US AN OPPORTUNITY TO
VOICE THEM TODAY. BEFORE I
OUTLINED OUR CONCERNS THOUGH I
WOULD WANT TO THINK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF HER STAFF
AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO HEAR OUT OUR
CONCERNS OVER THE PAST COUPLE
OF DAYS. THEY'VE BEEN GRACIOUS
WITH THEIR TIME AND ATTENTION
AND WE THANK THEM FOR THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK OUT PETER
AMENDMENTS OF ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS. OUR MAJOR CONCERNS
CAN BE OUTLINED IN FOUR POINT.
NUMBER ONE AS AMENDED AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE A LICENSE YOU TO REPLY
QUOTE REPLY WITHIN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS TO A CONSUMER WHO
CONTACTS THE LICENSEE FOR
CUSTOMER SERVICE ISSUES. AND IT
IMPOSES SPECIFIC OBLIGATIONS
WITH RESPECT TO THE REPLY.
THESE PRESCRIPTIVE REQUIREMENTS
FOR A TWENTY FOUR HOUR RESPONSE
WINDOW TO ANY OUTREACH TO THE
LICENSEE CONFLICT WITH OTHER
REGULATORY OBLIGATIONS OF
LICENSE FEES AND COULD ALSO
IMPERIL OUR ABILITY TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS FROM POTENTIAL
FRAUDULENT ACTIVITY. NUMBER TWO
WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED THAT THE
AMENDED- VERSION OF AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY- THE REQUIREMENTS TO
PROVIDE A QUOTE INDIVIDUALIZE
REPLY WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS
OF BEING CONTACTED- BY A
LICENSEE FOR CUSTOMER SERVICE
ISSUES WOULD CREATE SIGNIFICANT
COMPLIANCE AND LOGISTICAL
CHALLENGES FOR LICENSEES. AND
COULD DISRUPT PROCESSES
CURRENTLY IN PLACE TO ADDRESS
CUSTOMER CONCERNS AND ISSUES
RELATING TO LICENSEES PROVISION
OF MONEY TRANSMISSION SERVICES.
THE REQUIREMENT TO PROVIDE AN
INDIVIDUALIZED REPLY TO ANY
CONTACT RECEIVED BY THE
LICENSEE RELATING TO CUSTOMER
SERVICE ISSUES IS BROAD AND
VAGUE AND INCONSISTENT WITH
CURRENT NATIONWIDE STANDARDS OF
REGULATION FOR LICENSED MONEY%
TRANSMITTERS. IN MANY CASES
CONCERNS RELATING TO A
TRANSACTION CAN BE ADDRESSED
THROUGH THE USE OF AUTOMATED
PROCESSES INCLUDING
STANDARDIZED RESPONSES TO
COMMON QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
TAKE FOR EXAMPLE A REQUEST TO
RESET THE PASSWORD ON AN
ACCOUNT. IN THE CUSTOMER
SUPPORT WILL BE UNNECESSARILY
DELAYED AT SIGNIFICANT TIME AND
EXPENSE TO LICENSEES IF
LICENSEES ARE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE INDIVIDUALIZED
RESPONSES AS OPPOSED TO USING
EXISTING. PREPARED GUIDANCE
INFORMATION OR FEEDBACK THAT
CAN OFTEN TIMES PROMPTLY
ADDRESSED- CUSTOMERS SOME
CUSTOMERS CONCERNS. NUMBER
THREE WE ARE ALSO CONCERNED
ABOUT THE LACK OF AN EXCEPTION
IN THE BILL TAT WOULD ALLOW
LICENSEES TO NOT RESPOND TO
SUSPECTED FRAUDULENT ACTIVITY
ATTEMPTS. OUR MEMBER COMPANIES
TAKE PAINSTAKING EFFORTS TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS FROM FRAUD
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
DOCTOR AND FINDING WAYS TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S LANGUAGE
INCLUDED ON THIS POINT. NUMBER
FOUR WE ARE ALSO SEEKING
CLARIFICATION THE BILLING WHICH
ONLY APPLIES INTERACTIONS WITH
INDIVIDUAL CONSUMERS. AND NOT
HIGH VOLUME BUSINESS ACCOUNTS
WHICH ARE OFTEN TIMES MORE
CUMBERSOME. TO ADDRESS IN SUCH
A PRESCRIPTIVE TIME FRAME. WITH
THAT SHARE NUMBERS- WE AGAIN
THANKS B. FROM A NUMBER OF OUR
KING AND FOR HER WILLINGNESS
AND HER STAFF'S WILLINGNESS TO.
TO WORK WITH US OVER THE PAST.
FEW DAYS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AND AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT TODAY.
THANK YOU WE WILL MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY IN THE GALLERY.
C. NINE WE WILL MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE. SCENE AND THAT WE
WILL MOVE TO WITNESSES- WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION-
TELEPHONICALLY. MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT ANY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTEEN WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME PRESS. ONE NINE ZERO.
NO ONE IS SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK. THANK YOU MODERATOR
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OUR
DISCUSSION WITH MEMBERS MEMBERS
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
COENEN MOVE THE SEA NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ICE ICE
US SORRY SENATOR BRADFORD. ONCE
THE MICROPHONE. THREE ARE YOU
CHARGING SECURITY FOR THE
RESPONSE TO MR SAVANT AS
QUESTIONS AS IT RELATES TO- THE
ISSUES THAT HE RAISED WITH- THE
SEMI MEMBER MINDED DRESSING
THOSE ARE CLOSE THANK YOU AS A
MEMBER BARRICADE HOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO COMMENT ON THOSE. S.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR YES AND
THEY GET SENT AROUND FOR THE
QUESTION THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RESPOND AND WE ARE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH INDUSTRY. I THINK
THESE WERE IMPORTANT AMENDMENTS
TO ENSURE THAT AS YOU HEARD
WHEN YOU CALL PHONE LINES FOR
SOME OF THE SERVICES YOU GET A-
NO CUSTOMER SERVICE IS
AVAILABLE AT THIS TIME RESPONSE
AND SO WE WANTED TO ENSURE THAT
THIS BILL. GAVE MEANINGFUL
CUSTOMER SERVICE TO CONSUMERS.
ARE ABSOLUTELY IN CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THE TWENTY FOUR HOUR TIME
LINE ONE OF THE THING RAISED BY
THE COALITION WAS WHAT IF IT
COMES IN ON A FRIDAY FOR
EXAMPLE SO WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
THE TIME LINE AND WHAT IS A
REASONABLE TIME TO RESPOND. THE
INDIVIDUALIZED RESPONSE REPLY
IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE AGAIN WE
DON'T WANT THEM TO GET -
RESPONSE BACK THAT SAYS WE'RE
NOT AVAILABLE WHICH WOULD
QUALIFY AS A RESPONSE BUT NOT A
RESPONSIBLE MEETINGS WE PROVIDE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS. AND WE'RE
IN CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE
EXCEPTION FOR PROTECTING
AGAINST FRAUD OBVIOUSLY I AGREE
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT IMPORTANT
THING TO. STOP FROM AND THIS IS
A CONSUMER PROTECTION MEASURES
SO THAT IS OUR FOCUS WILL
CONTINUE. TO NARROWLY TAILOR
THE BILL WE ARE DOUBLE REFERRED
AND HEADING TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WHICH GIVES US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO FURTHER REFINE
THE LANGUAGE. THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER NAME AT
THANK YOU ASSIGNOR BARRICADE
HAND WE DO HAVE A MOTION FROM.
US SENATOR DOLLY. AND SEE NO I.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS WE WILL
GO AHEAD. AND A- OF A ON THE-
MATER SORRY. THE MOTION. THE
MOTION- IS IT DO YOU PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMENDED AND
RE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. LET ALONE HI THE
MON I SHOW ABOVE. BRADFORD
BRADFORD HI COPYRIGHT ZERO HI
DALLY BY DELHI HI THERE ALSO
RASO HI WHAT'S SO. WHAT'S SO HI
MEN MAN HI POURTANT TINO.
FORTINO HI. THE BILL HAS EIGHT
VOTES AND WE WILL PUT THAT BILL
ON CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS
AN AMERICAN HAND SO NOW WE WILL
GO THROUGH THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IN THIS IF YOU VOTED ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THIS BRINGS
OUR- HEARING TO A CLOSE. THE
MOTION IS TO ADOPT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BRADFORD. BRADFORD HI
WHAT'S SO WHAT'S SO HI MAN MAN
HI. THE CONSENT CALENDAR HAS
NINE VOTES AND WE WILL GO AHEAD.
AND PUT THAT ON THE WHOLE ORDER.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT SO
WE HAVE PUT A ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN TWENTY ON CALL. FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. BUT AND WE'RE
NOW WE ARE READY FOR ASSEMBLY
AND IF WE CAN LET THE CALL FOR
A. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY. THE
MOTION ON A. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY
IS DUE PASSES A MINUTE BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY OCHO ABOVE. OTOBO
GUY. THAT BILL ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN TWENTY MOVES OUT OF
THE COMMITTEE WITH NINE VOTES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND MEMBERS
WITH THAT WE WILL ADJOURN OUR
HEARING.